did you know what's his name Oh Jared
Leto tried stopping the Joker we have
that as a credit when he tried stopping
the production of Joker because he
thought by doing Suicide Squad Warner
Brothers guaranteed him to like the
spin-off the Joker so when he found out
Joaquin Phoenix got it more he flipped
the [ __ ] hours and agents
yeah flipped up that's crazy man yeah
this might have been this might be
attributed to Jared Leto and it might be
his lawyers who are doing this yeah I
wonder if Jared Leto Jared Leto wasn't
even in the conversation no he was as
far as like no no no you he had a no he
wasn't in the conversation as far as
Todd Phil right that's not but he didn't
know did he thought they were gonna do
the same thing got you and he used in
his contract it's kinda you know branch
off but now you can't do that now that
Todd Phillips did this like well no we
can't do it this get trumped whatever
the [ __ ] were trying yeah so it was a
violation maybe of his contract
yeah CAA was probably like ah yeah
apparently he really thought that he was
gonna get his own spin-off and he was
already upset with the whole Suicide
Squad situation because they marketed
the film to him as him being the main
villain but when you actually watch the
film he was in it for maybe five ten
minutes
yeah Cara Delevingne s character was the
main villain and so he thought he was
gonna get his standalone Joker movie and
then shortly after Todd Phillips
announced his Joker with Joaquin Phoenix
he was really upset by that tried to get
his team to stop the film which also is
the same team who represents Todd
Phillips they said no we're not gonna
try to do that and he ended up leaving
CAA for WME shortly after mm-hmm it's
true I find out yeah yeah my guess is
it's such a CA I didn't need any man
it's such a big role you know yeah well
a lot of people were also upset with
Jared Leto for his antics on Suicide
Squad did you hear about that he's like
sending wrath yeah he says Margot Robbie
a box with a live rat in a he sent a box
of bullets to Will Smith and a dead pig
to the actors who were in rehearsals
with Suicide Squad I loved Jared Leto
too much bro if I'm at home he sent me a
box of
bullets or I think he's by very strange
I just like all right dude I mean I
don't know how much of that is true
either by the way all these rumors
mm-hmm I don't believe any of this stuff
but my guess no he did said that's a
stranger stranger stranger
it's just that method acting but also
dude don't thought that would he pier
method acting
that's why rumors are that violence how
was he in this was he amazing
and I people hated him I like them I
like them as Joker a now compared to
walking Phoenix and Heath Ledger yeah
it's a [ __ ] tough go but I enjoyed
him but also you can't really judge it
cuz he's barely there he's barely in it
I thought it looked cool yeah he's gay
he's more of like a gangster Joker yeah
he was definitely more of a thug in this
yeah he's more like a well like a weird
thug whereas Joker was a good movie was
not good III liked it
he's a beautiful he's a beautiful young
man Oh beautiful tears Leto dine P I've
seen him in order sued me too and he's
just like he doesn't hate my son my son
yesterday he's got a bearded dragon it's
a [ __ ] you've had it for a while yeah
yeah you gotta feed it crickets and
guess what when you go to the [ __ ]
aquarium when you go to Alan's aquarium
they have a shitload of big snakes my
son is eight he doesn't really you know
I still you know he sees the worms the
dude drops a little baby mouse in the
[ __ ] cage his ball pythons if I send
my idea he goes why is he doing that and
that's just cool I'll shoot and rap song
and I go and my son goes oh yeah it's
just nature buddy he goes ah damn maybe
that's what he was he gotta buy to help
navigate through it then my other friend
decided to pick up I wasn't there to see
this when I got there she had picked up
a Goliath look up a Goliath tarantula a
bird Goliath bird-eating trans big boys
for a big boys yeah she picked that up
and got bit she got bit by at the dog I
said don't pick her a dumping home
because I have trash less it's fine
pick that bad boy up and it gave her a
cold all's Phangan now she said thing it
would have really hurt but he just gave
me a warning bite now [ __ ] you
hell [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I'm not going
near that why did she pick that thing up
cuz she's not afraid I wouldn't go near
that [ __ ] they eat birds look at
those [ __ ] fangs she said if it
wanted to bite me I would have had to
it's not real is it spent yeah that's
real that's a real spider my again [ __ ]
you MA oh my god man where do they live
in Australia of course I live in South
America
what does it say their home they live
everywhere a speedo Africa Australia the
tarantula the Goliath that on that one
though you know yeah says they're
probably South America Venezuela Brazil
French Guinea yeah all South America
deep rainforests Jesus Christ yeah dear
you know I thought your friend deserve
to get bit didn't you of course
don't be needy she was fine she was like
whatever I have to do non-venomous right
uh-huh
they're not venomous uh I don't think so
right they are not venomous but you know
they have giant [ __ ] teeth dude hang
I was never the kid that wanted a pet uh
weenie lighter or it's me neither me
neither
yeah do [ __ ] snakes I'm fine really you
deal with them harmless to humans yeah
but they still fight like July by a toss
11 inches across biggest one on record
because it's when Jesus Christ I thought
the biggest insect was the those spiders
in the desert others troops like holding
them up like those are desert camel
spiders yeah I thought those were the
biggest in the world I think I would say
a giant weight huh
the largest spider spider what's a giant
Wetty fungus ass like a grasshopper yeah
disco life yeah yeah I want to see the
giant [ __ ] let me see that [ __ ] you
don't like that better images
well well looks got big crap
I'll heat it the crab what crabs are
insect that they I was told that like
tarantulas he's like soft-shell crab
like they were truly have the same time
sure people he tranches yeah yeah to us
you just you got to burn their hair off
I would imagine I seen him on sticks
yeah in we're at in somewhere in Asia I
remember I had to follow Patrice O'Neal
in at Caroline's and they had him
feature for me he was just filling in do
it something that we and I'd never seen
Patrice work live and he was you know
I'd seen him on TV and stuff like that
you just he's just sat on the stool told
story he was kind of chewing his teeth
or his Lippert just the whole time just
doing this and talking and the the
audience just loved him so much he also
did about an hour in the feature slot I
got moving Patrice until he's done he
just he had stuff to say and I was
intrigued by it but at the same time I'm
going yeah it's uh it's midnight already
yeah and the it's been an hour and a
half of show and I haven't gone up yet
can I just do 15 and get out of here Wow
like nobody really knew who I was it
also didn't even matter but I'm like
this is brew cuz he's just killed so he
just hasn't been the palm of his hands
he's taught he's just taking his time I
go up and I got you know I'm like a
puppet show without the puppets just
doing you know impressions I have at
that point I have some jokes but I don't
have as many as I do now and I don't set
it up as well and I had no confidence in
being myself I was just good at being
the characters at that point and I I did
alright I survived it was like a tough
go she's that's that's the real de an
artist like you're following a dude
tidal wave yeah and he was young back
then he's just I mean I I don't even
know I couldn't even tell you the year
it was it was in the 2000 did you do mo
sure kind of stand up in New York well
you know I just was I was just doing the
airlines that I I started in Chicago and
Milwaukee my introduce O'Neill was
that's right yes my Angelus
O'Neil was was I didn't know him I'd
seen him out because of New York I would
see him and but I never paid much
attention he was always great and I'm
sitting with Dov Davidoff and we start
talking and this is probably I don't
know maybe 10 years ago maybe a little
less and he starts we start talking
about women and relationships he starts
dropping like knowledge on relationships
and how women have different levels of
karate different levels of karate that
they pull out year 1 year 5 that's
American bro
and it wasn't comedy he was drunk and I
at one point I'm an old man I mean I've
heard a lot of [ __ ] it was so deep and
so smart that I went I looked at him and
I looked at Dov and I go you do you here
in this and Dov just goes he drops a
heavy dish rooster you know I'm just
I've been out of it for a while I wasn't
my kids I was trying to help raise my
kids and now I found out that they
didn't need me the whole time I've been
fine without me
they need their I power breaking I swear
I'd be super clean because now I just
hear my son playing NBA 2k yeah and
there's just F this at just everything's
fly hold is he 15 and my son's 8 he's
doing that [ __ ] yeah he doesn't think
I'm listening [ __ ]
god damn I'm like hey dude I know I
swear all the time but you can't copy me
I tryna I did like he called me chuckle
nuts oh hey all right chuckling oh wait
that's five years and he's the Chuckle
nuts is where's that he's from you
Orfila that had been for my son's
[ __ ] hilarious I've never said
chuckle nuts in my life but I got to
tell you that it has to be from you if
there's a born comedian that
[ __ ] at chuckling that kid is a
comedian through and through so I think
there's something about when your dad is
a commuter and a parents of comedian
there's something to that because my
son's the same way and my son is super
dark my son he named his phone so when
somebody comes by and wants to airdrop
something or seizure I jump his phone is
named Jeffrey Epstein's phone what
Arius so see that's a sophisticated so
fat this is great yeah it's great
watching if it's if it's chapelle up I
had to watch her pal because I wanted to
see her great tall watch I talked to I
talked to you about this too after I saw
you because I considered that another
level as well thank you but it was it
was that when you were tired you did it
and a few comedians I've gone to see are
all doing everybody's kind of going this
against the grain thing and especially
in clubs nobody's staying completely PC
they're walking a line of and I think it
all comes down to tone like what's your
tone of something is your tone to try
and hurt somebody I get that as being a
negative but if your tone is hey we're
different let's celebrate our
differences and see if that can make
each but if we can make each other laugh
with that that's what it's all about
that's about compromise and let's get
away with it is that what you took from
Chapelle special though did you find a
look I did I watched Appel special and I
said this is this is great this is
helpful to comedians I think it's first
- yeah I haven't seen birds yet I had to
do them slowly because it says I've had
to force myself I know how great
Chapelle is yeah but some of the stuff
he's doing I'm going and it was rated so
terribly by all the critics the stuff it
was the world critics because the
critics are terrified of taking a stand
themselves because then they'll get out
and lose their status right we live in a
society where finding the the race is
finding the misogynist that's what where
you get credit that's what you get
currency from that yeah you'll get
currency from being moderate and nuanced
in your thinking right trying to
understand somebody is a negative